Speaker 1: You know, when the FBI does a raid,
they already probably have a pretty good case
and a pretty substantive suspicion about wrongdoing
that has taken place.
The FBI has raided the home of radical Republican
Congresswoman Lauren Boebert, ex campaign
manager.
This is not a good sign for Lauren Boebert.
Lauren Boebert, let's read this article from
Salon by Igor Dariush.
The FBI on Tuesday raided the home of a Colorado
election clerk and three others in an investigation
into a voting system security breach.
Mesa County Clerk Tina Peters, a Republican,
was accused by state officials in August of
helping to leak voting system passwords to
a right wing blog.
I thought the left was doing the voter fraud.
Peters later appeared at MyPillow CEO Mike
Lindell's conspiracy laden, laden cyber symposium,
or symposium.
As MyPillow refers to it were the pillow magnate
promised but failed to produce evidence of
election rigging.
Peters later briefly went into hiding with
Lindelof's help amid FBI scrutiny.
We covered that when it happened.
You might remember we did the story.
Mike Pillow is helping to hide an official
accused of tampering.
So that's this individual.
On Tuesday morning, the FBI and local prosecutors
raided Peter's home.
We executed four federal court authorized
operations today to gather evidence in connection
with the investigation.
We did so with assistance from the DA's office
from the 21st Judicial District, the Attorney
General's Office and the FBI, said District
Attorney Dan Rubenstein.
Yes, Dan Rubinstein and yes, there are already
anti-Semitic comments on the fact that this
took place.
If you find that if you look online at the
comments not encouraging you to do it, but
you can.
Peters is on is an interview in an interview
on Lindell's online streaming channel, said
the raid left her quote terrified.
The FBI also raided a home in Garfield County.
Lindell said one of the homes raided belongs
to Sirona Bishop A. Garfield County resident,
who served as Lauren Boebert, campaign manager.
Bishop has been one of Peter's most prominent
allies in stoking unfounded allegations of
voting machine problems in the election, and
hinted at a rally last month that she was
privy to unreleased data from Mesa County.
This is every every element of this is absolutely
crazy.
The FBI raided my home as of 6:00 a.m. this
morning, accusing me of committing a crime.
They raided the homes of my friends, mostly
older women.
I was terrified.
They used a battering ram to destroy one of
her friend's front doors.
They took all my electronics.
They were soldiers in combat gear, not men
in suits with badges.
They looked like they were in a combat zone.
Man, you know the same.
It's so funny because we've been against no
knock warrants for so long, for not you.
Obviously for nonviolent offenses, and then
beyond that, we can have a conversation.
These folks have been for no knock warrants
forever, and now all of a sudden they're saying
they're coming in like it's a war zone.
Yes, that's what we've been saying all along.
And the allegations in this entire fiasco
are pretty wild.
They include that the elections Clark gave
out passwords to their systems deliberately
ran from the FBI with the help of Mike Pillow
helping to hide them.
But we're supposed to believe it's the Democrats
that committed the election fraud, given that
this is what's going on.
It's crazy.
It is absolutely crazy.
And they probably have something very serious
here.
And whether it will hit Lauren Boebert, we
just don't know yet.
But it very well may remember when we talk
about the FBI in recent years raiding people
from the Republican Party.
We are aware of folks who shared internal
campaign materials with Russia.
We have folks associated with Trump who were
subsequently indicted for tax evasion, bank
fraud.
Remember Michael Cohen?
Some of the folks who remain friendly with
Donald Trump ultimately received pardons for
the things they were convicted of.
But when the FBI starts starts the raids,
it's not looking particularly good.
FBI agents don't tend to go after political
staffers, ex campaign managers, et cetera,
unless they have a really serious case already.
Remember when they some of you might remember
this, you may not.
There was that Congressman Jefferson, who
whose office and home were raided and there
were bricks of cash in the freezer, and the
FBI already knew exactly what they were looking
for at the point that the raids start.
They already have a lot of information, and
that seems to be exactly what is going on
here.
So do you believe it will eventually hit?
Lauren Boebert, I guess, is the main question
I have for you right now.
Let me know your thoughts, and we're going
to have more coverage of this on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.
We also maybe tomorrow, maybe Monday will
be announcing the next viewer town hall.
The one we did in October, went wild, extremely
popular event where everybody gets to call
in.
And of course, members get priority will be
announcing the next one for early December,
tomorrow or Monday.
So stay tuned for that.
We're going to take a quick break and be
right back.